we are the fastest pole dancers in the
world
can you keep up
this great big story was made possible
by geico believe it geico could save you
fifteen percent or more on car insurance
i'm ahmed
i am gay i am and we are the preacher we
combine
hungarian traditional folk dancing
with modern dance ties and rhythms we
started dancing about 20 years ago akbar
musa is one of my best friends we grew
up together and mate is my younger
brother so
so we can't avoid each other
we learned the hungarian folk dances not
just from the training room but we made
researches hungarian folk dancing has
got big archive recordings and we learn
the dance from them one of our biggest
influencer is michael flackley and the
way he made irish tap dancing world
famous he made 35 steps in one second
we are hungary and pork dancers we use
our feet and hands dance start with the
basics
and after that you can build up your own
style
we need a lot of practice for this in
common
we
do 20 hours a week in 2014
we set over the court we hit and slapped
3937 times in two minutes
ahmed was the fastest from us he made 41
slaps and hits in one second
so our hands after a lot of hits gets
injured yeah yeah it hurts
[Laughter]
we would like to make hungarian fork
culture more popular throughout the
world we have got a great responsibility
how we carry on and continue our
heritage
we imagine our life with dancing and we
imagine our future with fritzko
[Music]
you